طب يلاقينا من الاستديو عبد العزيز بن صقر
رئيس ااه مركز الخليج اللي بح- الدكتور
عبد العزيز حياك الله اهلا وسهلا
دكتور المتابع
لتصريحات الايرانيه يجد ان هناك تهافت من
قبل خاصه تندبلوماسيه الايرانيه في توجيه
دعوات للحوار مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
اخرها ما قاله المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الايرانيه ان الارض ممهد لتحسين العلاقات
مع الرياض لذلك حقيقيه
ولما مساء الخير لك استاذ خالد المشاهدين
العربيه في كل مكان الحقيقه يعني المملكه
نمت مانع من اقامه هذا الحوار يعني كان
هنالك حوالي خمسه جولات حواليه تم عقدها
في بغداد وتم نقاش في كثير من القضايا
ولكن الفرق ان السلوك الايراني لم يتغير
في المملكه لا تريد ان تعيد علاقه وايران
دون تغيير السلوك وجدنا حينما غير تركيا
من سلوكان المملكه
تركيا ويعني الان تعادل علاقه بكافه انشطه
الى ما كانت عليه طبيعته الايرانيين لهم
مصلحه في عهد العلاقه المملكه لا تمانع من
اعاده العلاقه ولكن السؤال هو الذي يطرح
نفسه هنالك ما زال نفس السلوك الايراني
سياسه التدخليه سياسه توسعيه دعم
الميليشيات الموجوده التدخل في الشان
العراقي ودعم الحشد الشعبي للقيام حتى في
مناطق حدوديه قريبه المملكه ببعض
التجهيزات التي وردت حواليها بعض الاخبار
المهمه في هذا الجانب همم
النطاقها الاعلامي على سبيل المثال هي
تطلع وكاله الانباء الايرانيه تقول عن
مصدر لبناني او الصحيفه او تلفزيون اخر
انهم قالوا كذا ان المملكه سوف تنفذ احكام
يعني كذا شيء هي تشترط وتقول ان محطه
التلفزيون الايرانيه الناس التي يتمناها
المعارضه الايرانيه هي هي ايضا
تتلقى معلوماتها من الداخل الايراني لديها
والحقائق فيتضع يعني تجعل نقاط اشياء في
ظاهرها تبدي الرغبه لكن المملكه لا تريد
هذه العوده بالشروط الايرانيه تريد ان
تكون الشروط الايرانيه او على ماذا تركز
ايران اليوم في اي جوله محادثات او
مفاوضات او اعاده لرسم العلاقات مع الرياض
الدرجه الاولى هي تنكر اي شيء من هذا
التداخللات هي دائما تنكر طبيعه الاعمال
التدخليه التي تقوم بها هي تتدخل في سوريا
وفي العراق وفي اليمن وفي لبنان
يعني قامت فهي تنكر اول شيء هذا الجانب
وتقول انها تدعم طلب الحكومات الشرعيه هنا
ولك هذا غير صحيح وهذه اولويات عند الجانب
السعودي
بالنسبه للمملكه سياده الداخليه والسياسه
توسعيه غير مقبوله ايضا هي تحاول استخدام
البعد الطائي في كوسيله ما ننسى انه ايران
هنالك تهديد على الممرات المائيه هي قامت
به تمام يعني بشكل واضح في منطقه الخليج
وفي ايضا مضيق باب المندب
الضرب المنشات النفطيه هي من قام بتوجيه
ضربات الى شقيقه
المنشات السعوديه النفطيه هي من تواجد في
العراق ودعم هي من يعني يوجه ضربات الى
شمال العراق والتدخل في الشان العراقي في
هذا الجانب فهذه كلها اعمال يعني غير
مقبوله البرنامج النووي والبرنامج
الصاروخي هو مسؤوليه دوليه يتحمل مسؤوليه
المجتمع الدولي وليس فقط دول منطقه لكن
دول المنطقه شعرت حينما يبرر لايران في
المفاوضات عدم ذكر الاجند الاقليميه هذا
غير مقبول فلذلك لا يمكن ان اقبل بمفاوضه
مع الجانب الايراني دون ان يقبل ان يدخل
في تفاصيل هذه النقاط والادله واضحه
والنقاط واضحه يعني لدرجه انه في احد
الاجتماعات مسؤول الايراني كان يقول
لمسؤول سعودي تحدثه مع الحرس الثوري
الايراني انا مع من اتحدث هذه النقطه
تحديدا يعني في الوقت الذي تاتي فيه
التصريحات من الخارجيه همم الايرانيه
باعاده
ضاعت وغيرها من الامور تصريحات ناعمه
تاتي في تتزامن مع همم اسماعيل القاني
مثلا على سبيل المثال والتصريحات التي يشم
فيها هجوم العده على المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من الذي يحدد اذا السياسه
الخارجيه للنظام الايراني هل هذه
التصريحات تؤثر على اي نوايا بالتالي وعلى
اي توجه ربما محتمل المملكه العربيه
السعوديه في الدخول في مفاوضات مع ايران
املا يعني منذ فتره السابقه في يعني قبل
الرئيس ابراهيم رئيس الوصول الى السلطه
كنا دائما نرى ان المرشد الاعلى ومكتبه
والحرس الدولي هم من يقررون السياسات
الداخليه في المنطقه لذلك حتى ما حكمه
ابراهيم رئيس وزير الخارجيه يعني حديث ومن
باب ال- ال- ال- انا اسمي توزيع الادوار
في الجانب الايراني وتوزيع الادوار هذه
قضيه ولفنا عليها لكن ال- ال- الذي بد في
القرار هو المرشد الاعلى وهو الحرس الثوري
الايراني هو الذي من يموت في هذا لانه هو
من يعني وجدنا زياره رئيس الحرس الثوري
الى الى العراق
في تحديد مواقع بالقرب من الحدود السعوديه
العراق
وكانهم يجهزون بعض تجهيزات ويؤكدون على
اهميه الانتقال يعني مجموعات من حشد
الشعبي لهذا المكان هذه قضيه غير مقبوله
يعني انت اعاده العلاقه على فكره لها
مستويات ممكن اعيدها على مستوى القنصليه
المستوى نائب السفير المستوى السفير
والمملكه مانع كيظهار حسني النيه انني
اقبل بالالتقاء المباشر والتفاوض دون ان
يكون هنالك بحاجه الى وسطها نعرف الاجنده
الايرانيه وما يريدون وما يعرفون ما يريده
لا نريد التدخل في الشان الداخلي وعلى
فكره المملكه حتى يعني لما كان كل الحراك
في داخل الايران هي لم تدلي بتصريح واحد
له علاقه بالحراك الداخل داخل ايران لن
تعتبر ان هذا شان داخلي ولا تقبل في
التدخل في شان الداخلي لاي دوله من الدول
لكن مع الاسف الشديد السلوك الايراني بهذه
الطريقه لا يمكن ان يكون مقبول ولا يمكن
لانه على فكره هذا لو انا قبلت اني اعيد
العلاقه معه بهذا الوضع وبهذا السلوك
وبهذه التصرفات معناته اني انا قبلت
ضمينيا كل هذه التصرفات فرح تعطيها المجال
في التوسع كما يريد هل يمكن التعويل على
لان هذه القضيه بالتاكيد هي مهمه ومؤثره
للدول العظم يعني تحدث عن روسيا التي لها
علاقه كبيره مع ايران مع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين بعد الزياره الاخيره التي قام بها
يعني الى الى الرياض فبالتالي هل يمكن
التعويل هنا على روسيا الامريكيه وحتى
صينيه ربما في اعاده التفاوض بين الرياضه
ولكن بحاجه الى مواقف من هذه الدول واضحه
الضمانات يعني بمعنى انه اذا كانت ايران
هي من يدعم الحوت في اليمن في ايران لها
علاقه قويه مع الصين كثير من اسلحتها
وتصنيعها واجهزها وامداد ياتي من الصين
العلاقه التجاريه الكبرى هي مع الصين ايضا
روسيا لها علاقه قويه ايران في هذا الجانب
اذا ارادت هذه الدول ان تستمتع وان ان ان
تستفيد من العلاقه السعوديه المتوازنه ما
بين كل الاطراف فعليها ان تقف موقف واضح
وهذا الكلام سمعناه في زياره الرئيس
الصيني الاخير حينما لاول مره يوجه بعدم
التدخل في الشان الداخلي للدول الاقليميه
وكانت ايران مزعجه الامر اللي جعلها
تستدعي السفير الصيني في في في طهران
وتتحدث معه في هذا الجانب روسيا ايضا يعني
مصلحتها الحقيقيه تكون في ان تكون في
علاقه جيده مع الاطراف نحن نعلم مصلحتها
مع ايران ولكن من الواضح انه هذه العلاقه
مع طهران لن تمكينها من من اشياء مستقبليه
تريدها لا ينكر اننا بدانا مرحله جديده في
الحرب البارده وهذه المرحله الجديده هي
اعاده تشكيله التحالفات المملكه استطاعت
ان تحافظ على موقف متوازي من كل الاطراف
وهذا الموقف المتوازن هو الذي مكانها ان
ان ان تكون يعني في موقع افضل بكثير من
الغير والكل يلجا وياتي اليها لياخذ
الموقف اساس في الموقف القديم طيب في ضوء
هذه المواقع يعني وربما اذا جاز لنا وصف
تحفظ ربما من الرياض تجاه اي مفاوضات همم
بعيدا عن القضايا الجوهريه المهمه في
المنطقه اليمن الخليج التدخل في في العراق
سوريا لبنان وغيرها
وموقف ايران التي تريد فقط التركيز على
اعاده العلاقات بين همم البلددين هنا كيف
يمكن النظر الى الافق والتحديات التي يمكن
ان تشهدها المنطقه في ضوء هذا التباين في
المواقف باستمرار الصراعات استمرار
المواقف الايرانيه في التدخل يعني
مختلفه احد السنه استمرار هذا التصعيد في
العلاقه ما بين المملكه و بعد دول الخليج
معها ايران ربما يدفع ايراد لتوجيه عمليات
عسكريه واستخدام الهارد سكيوريتي ما يسمى
بالهارسكيوتي» ربما هذا يدفع ايران لدعم
الحوثي اكثر وتحفيزه لتوجيه ضربات جديده
اخرى سواء في الداخل اليمني في منطقه مارب
او على يعني بعض الدول الخليجيه المجاوره
هذه ربما تكون ردت فعل والتصعيد من الجانب
الايراني ولكن يجب ان نكون مستعدين عليها
لانه النقطه الاساسيه دائما في التفاوض
كلما قدمت تنازل فالطرف الاخر سوف يطلب
المزيد معه اعتبره مكسب ويرى انه هذا ضعف
المملكه ليست ضعيف الحمد لله قادر ان
تدافع عن نفسه وقادر ان تتحمل تبيعات هذا
القرار وما ينتج عنه الدول الغربيه بما
فيها اوروبا يعني احنا الان نشعر بان
اوروبا بدات تقاطع رسميا همم المانيا على
سبيل المثال كانت اكثر دوله لها علاقه
قويه مع ايران الان لا تستقبل الوفود
السياسيه الان ترفض بعض الانشطه او كافه
النشاط الاقتصادي والثقافي والسياسي
المانيا
فهذا الموقف الاوروبي جاء متاخر سنين
طويله ولكنه اتى الموقف الامريكي اللي راى
انه يعني عدم قبول
بشيل قائمه الحرس الثوري وادخال هذا
الموضوع في المفاوضات البرنامج النووي لم
يقبل انا بالامريكي بهذا روسيا والصين سوف
تستيقظ من سباتها يعني الان الصين بدات
تستيقر انا الان يعني اشعر بانه سين بدت
تشعر بعد زياره الرئيس الصيني واجتماعه
بالزعماء والقاده العرب والخليجين تحت
مظله الزعامه والقياده السعوديه استشعرت
الصين بانه صحيح ايران علاقه مهمه لانه
افغانستان وباكستان واكبر دوله انا مصدق
لها في المنطقه ولكن بالمقابل العلاقه مع
بقيه الدول يجب ان تكون تراعى فيها
مصالحها الجوهريه والاساسيه شكرا جزيلا
الدكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر رئيس مركز
الخليج شكرا